doodly-doo going down the mountain
doodlee do hello so I just spent all day
recording well not all day but I
recorded a bunch of videos today and
I've been really loving playing super
flight it's just like a very relaxing
like so even though it's like
horrendously nerve-racking with like the
the risk of death flying around every
corner I just kind of had fun with it so
I wasn't paying attention I probably
should look while I'm flying down a
mountain I'm trying to get a high score
but every time I get like some good
moves
I try to be fancy about it and so I
shoved my head up my own a noose and
then I I'm just an [ __ ] about it and
then I don't go anywhere
so this is a weird one what the hell oh
my god I've never seen a map like this
is so cool
whee three points Oh getting fancy oh I
know it's so cool yeah I think it's
randomly generated I'm not I represent
sure honestly it's a fun fun fun
adventure joke nice my high score is
dismal II low right now because for some
reason I can't keep a streak going to
save my life oh no see that happens I
get stupid you're a man in like a
wingsuit like one of those cliff diving
wingsuits like squirrel suits or
whatever they call them how
non-represented we're sure but yeah it's
one of those suits and you're going
around and you're being an idiot tiny
tiny tiny nailed it why wasn't that a
bonus stupid the window to the wall to
the sweat drip down my forehead I'm an
idiot double oh come on it's not worth
double double dagger piece of garbage
just circle back around oh now I got the
speed for it oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh
it's such a fun I almost lost it I don't
know why but I almost lost that please
give me enough speed I know that I can't
make those and then
okay good news good news have you heard
the good news the good news is I'm not
terribly stupid and this guy hasn't died
yet oh my god oh okay great great
it's not going in that portal just yet
we've got too much good stuff here
ooh way too close uh ah how about this
one no I'm not gonna make that one note
I would not I I knew I wouldn't have
made that one so it's good call on my
part I'm a smarty can I make anything
else no okay all right sure it's good
it's good
all right cool oh so the way this game
works is exactly like if you were
wingsuiting down a mountain you kind of
just just slam your face and break your
everything every bone in your body gets
broken so that's that's literally the
only way to play so it's the only way to
do it in real life too I guess I don't
understand anyone that would actually do
this in real life like I get it the
adrenaline rush is what people go for
but personally like it's just like the
risk for the reward oh that is not
anything Oh God
see I get up to like 20 to 30,000 and
then I just lose it because I play it
fast and loose like an idiot oh that did
not go well for that guy it is why
Cooper this is what I couldn't do it in
real life
that's why I would never do in real life
because I would die like just plain and
simple I would just die tiny Oh God
there is no saving it there's no second
chances for me it is just pure Oh I'm
not gonna make that yeah I don't even
think that gap is get about if it is
gettable it's so precise that it's not
definitely not worth trying for but here
I go again
ah haha I made it in the hole that means
it's possible okay ah so close I just
want to get this is super fun oh come on
I was right there
uh-oh it's millimeters it's millimeters
this millimeters okay
on target yeah yes yes yes oh yes oh
oh yes oh yes oh yes come on set it get
it
really I'll never break the twenty
thousand barrier because I'll always be
stupid a B yes always why do I choose to
do things the hard way okay cuz it's
more satisfying C this is C I say I
don't get why people do the whole
adrenalin junkie thing and yet here I am
I am pursuing the hard ones because it's
more fun so who I thought I didn't get
that I thought I didn't get that I got
an achievement but I didn't get that
okay I see a small silhouette of a man
who fitting through a hole yeah uh yeah
it feels good endorphins in my brain uh
uh trees watch out alright got some here
just go for the small hole I like it a
small hole and you can quote me on that
yes points yes points
yes point not worth it though is not
worth it alright let's see if we can
keep up his speed
ooh this one looks fun and horrifying
yeah I bet I hope there's a gap through
this oh good there is it looks good
that's a good approach ooh bad approach
bad ah okay we're fine we're fine we're
fine
everything's fine oh man I'm sizzling oh
yeah oh yeah this is a dead end this is
a dead end
no it's not it feels good endorphins in
my brain
hahaha new high score yeah don't tell me
to get I got an achievement called get a
life you shut your mouth I know exactly
what I'm doing with my life and it is
taking a break by screaming at a game
and is supposed to be an emulation of a
very death-defying sport how many people
die from doing this probably a lot yeah
oh yeah oh yeah okay ah do I have enough
speed I probably don't
here we go anyway oh no here we go okay
all right oh boy why did I do that
there was no reason there's just no
reason squeeze okay
odds of dying in any base-jump activity
is one in two thousand three hundred and
seventeen I guess that's not that bad I
guess it's not really odds is it it's
it's not really up to odds that's
probably the statistical odds but not
the the practical odds see if if I were
to try to base jump I would die because
I'm an idiot and I'm not good at that
like how do you even practice Oh No
please whoa whoa I saved it I saved it I
am amazing I am amazing did you guys see
how amazing I was almost doing there
there's no gap I was doing so good I was
doing so good why do I try why do I
bother trying in life I don't know why
don't I just like let my failures be the
lesson that I learned and just remember
that I shouldn't try I mean that's
obviously what this game is telling me
there's no gap there I almost did it
again
but I learned my lesson my failures have
taught me well
Oh whoa where am I going where am I
going where am I going where am I going
oh god oh god is this what it's like to
be a fighter pilot or a bird or a flying
squirrel hmm oh gosh so scary all right
I'm out I'm out I know that's right it
was good enough don't freak out don't
freak out oh my god there's no way out
oh my god I found a way oh my god that
was amazing oh my god I have the biggest
boner right now okay all right we're
fine everything's fine I don't know how
any of that has this happened but okay
oh so scary I think I peed my pants too
tight a gap yeah yeah ooh getting all
kinds of oh oh that was too small it was
too small oh boy here we go
fancy maneuver Oh fancy maneuver not
really fancy it's kind of gold I call it
the go down maneuver it's just where I
go down a lot a ye okay let's try as uno
mas we're going in starting my attack
run why did I do that I was doing so
good I was doing so good I survived all
those amazing amazing maneuvers I
survived all the death-defying stunts
and I like maliciously slammed this
character's head into a wall for some
reason just because I like pain because
I think some part of me like just
automatically knows that I'm doing good
in some aspect and it's like you need to
shut that [ __ ] down mark can remember
you're not a success so you just shut up
and get back to your corner of failure a
little bit and it causes me to just do
the stupidest things imaginable at any
moment and
that's how I live my life that's what
happens in my life I'm not doing it oh
if it wasn't obvious in this game you
get points the closer you are to objects
so the more death-defying your stunts
are obviously the more points you get
just like real life
right and you can build up some sweet
combos by staying real close to things
why-why-why oh geez okay I'm starting my
attack run oh I need to stop saying I'm
starting my attack run because I'm
pretty sure that's the that's the code
for the game to kill me here we go on
the attack run what a good attack run
we've got here fellow gems oh I'd like
to think I'm just sending clones of Jim
off into their death I've started my
attack run oh god why do I keep saying
it it is what's killing me
it is 100% what's killing me I've
started my attack run oh can I just get
one please I just want one sweet sweet
savory swears slavery attack run that's
all I want ass Waverly save early attack
run yes starting my attack run I'm sorry
my attack run I'm attacking my run my
runs I might in my [ __ ] is running right
now I've got running all right there we
go oh I almost land right into a Bowser
again so close so close so close there
buddy throw ham so bloody close
Oh going for it shouldn't have gone for
it that was a lesson that I learned
there that junk trash shouldn't try in
life he should just give up as soon as
he possibly humanly can and then you
will only experience joy at that point
you can finally live your life without
worrying about ooh the problems of
society oh I'm going for it
oh that's a sweet sweet nuzzle oh yeah
I've started my attack run my attack run
might have been an error oh that looks
like a gap awesome
Oh another one your ass another one
Oh mistake you're about to see that was
intentional to show you what not to do
now you're about to see some pro level
gaming that I know you come for and I
know you stay for and it is from me to
you that I send the love that I am
showing you right now like a bullet
through the sky oh oh yeah yeah you know
what I'm not gonna go for those anymore
I'm just gonna go like why do I keep
going for the tunnels I don't have to go
for the tunnels you can just like go get
a better combo get like the multiplier
up and then oooh right and then you get
plenty of points too and it's not as
many points obviously it's some points
there's not as many so I guess it's not
as fun well wind what that was that wind
did wind blew me wait can wind blow you
in this game can anything blow you in
this game can you get blowed in this
game oh what a handy feature possible so
I mean there is window and the camera
does oh okay alright that was my fault
oh yeah oh yeah oh that was right on the
belly
I nailed that with my Tumtum I felt my
navel scrape along the ground there a
pleasant sensation if ever there was one
oh wow
everybody celebrate how great I am in
your own way to make sacrifices
sacrificial lamb for how cruel I am
alright cool cool cool I don't ask most
of my fanbase only that they make a
Blood Pact no here just remember yeah
you think back to a moment in your life
when you're like okay I have the chore
you ever think back to a moment in your
life when you're just like I have the
choice whether I'm gonna live my life as
a productive member of society or I'm
gonna live my life screaming at a video
game that I could be good at but for
some reason I actively choose not to be
good at it you know you remember ever I
think everybody remembers that moment in
their life when they experienced you
know that that conundrum of choice and
they have to look within themselves and
be like okay I know I'm gonna be a loser
yeah I'm gonna believe loser and then
that is what you is and that's what I am
and that's how I got to where I am today
so if you want to have the same level of
success that I do which is none just
remember just to admit that you're a
loser and don't do anything worth a damn
in life and then you'll be fine no fear
fear fear fear one favor two fears many
fears one fears breaking all my bones in
my body the other is standing naked in
front of an auditorium so the tasteful
nudes are gonna be a little strange for
me yo whoa camouflage itself I didn't
see the giant floating pillar anywhere
who could have seen it you came out of
nowhere I gotta get a little ballsier
this is gonna take forever okay here we
go after my attack run well this is a
mistake okay
there's no attack run to be had in there
who break art whoa I almost made that
one that was pretty good okay well
there's a Ledge there whoa ah almost
ah what the hell is happening there I
was like getting blown all over the
place that can't be wind if there was
wind in this game it would like ruin
like the sense of skill oh oh oh I am
very fortunate that the formation of the
hill went as thusly because otherwise
why I just want to get a good school
nope not gonna do it I was tempted to do
it by on the safe route is gonna be the
high school run you know why cuz I'm
starting my 10 [ __ ] yeah that's the
stuff oh yeah that's the stuff when
someone asks for the stuff they're gonna
point to this and they're gonna be like
that that that right there is the stuff
I'm gonna be like oh yeah yeah I
recognize that stuff that's good stuff
yes that is the stuff what's going to
portal go to portal Hall alright let's
study this I see a spot risky but I like
it know what's in here I wonder I wonder
death ah okay okay alright we made it we
made it okay oh where am I going where
I'm going where my God where am I going
Oh break okay mm I got to a triple scar
nice portal time oh you okay
I'm starting my attack run oh no I said
it oh no what's gonna happen am I gonna
die
oh yeah very likely very likely very
very very likely okay I have begun oh
boy this attack run is going very poorly
not bad no holes to go through but you
know you know this is a gap oh this is a
gap this gap that goes nowhere no I
could've broke right oh there's lots of
gaps up yeah
I like how it says awesome right before
I died as if I didn't know how bad I was
already whoo that's a good gap that's
good yeah oh that's a bad gap whoa whoa
whoa whoa come on I was doing so Gucci
and yes okay where is this going I don't
want to go through this one now this one
just sucks it sucks it sucks it sucks
all right you know what I'm gonna play
it safe this time all I'm gonna do is
I'm just gonna put lay it nice and safe
play it super safe I'm gonna play it
super nice one just like coast real
chill about things I'm just gonna go
down the the easy gaps I'm not gonna go
for the big bonkers I'm just gonna
cruise because cruising is where it's at
please please please oh I'm not going
for that gap as fun as that would be not
doing it cuz dying is not nearly as fun
as living I think I missed all of the
portals that's all right I don't need
them you know why cuz I've got you guys
right I can always count on you guys
Oh what hell is this what fresh hell
have I walked into this is oh that was
actually a gap who'd have thought oh oh
I suck I suck I suck I don't suck I
don't suck guys guys did you hear the
good news I don't suck who don't suck at
all I've got like ant I suck I in fact I
blow I blow guys guys I blow yes yes yes
oh I'm actually concentrating I'm gonna
try
this one is I'm doing good we were
shockingly good no one could have ever
expected this out of a little little boy
out of Cincinnati Ohio from a small town
called Milford no one could have
possibly anticipated whoa no one could
have ever surmised no I lost my combo
okay never mind okay bye Oh my scores
gonna be so beefy there's gonna be a
good one I can feel it guys No oh my god
are you kidding me
are you yanking me oh I haven't seen any
good opportunities to even try to do any
like sick maneuvers which is probably
why I'm surviving up until this point I
mean I've gone through a few gaps but
nothing that would equate to a sick
nasty maneuver yeah hold on nothing all
right
well off I go to the next one nice nice
nice nice sick nasty nice sick nasty
okay Bailey uh-huh got scared I got
scared and bailed and I'm only getting
like 4,000 per level so I don't even
know if I'm actually close to my eye
score which is like 69000 but I don't
think I'm actually close to my high
score because I haven't been able to
actually go through it oh never mind
then new high score
everybody shut me up he's shoving dick
in me and call me Sally I need to shut
my mouth okay there we go oh why my why
my no no no I said as I was doing it why
am I going Oh
[Music]